this video is for trap doors in pepper
panic saga
it goes along with our trap doors guide
um just basically explaining the
they're pretty straightforward but
explaining the you know how they work
this is level 187
and it's pretty simple in the way
they're set up you can see at the bottom
we have three
entrance trapdoors
and
at the top we have three exit trans
trap doors
so the entrance ones have little blue
arrows on the top
and the exits have little red
arrows at the bottom and that shows that
it goes in here and comes out there
these ones are all in order
they're not really confusing at all
and if you read the guides you know that
by making matches underneath them that's
how
you get them to open up and transfer
your peppers
if you've ever played candy crush um
you're probably familiar with these
already
it's uh these things they look like this
and candy crush
on this level they're connected
crossways so
basically we have entry here exit here
and so if we make a match down here
these candies move that way
and so you can move them from one pla
place to the other
like that
they work pretty much the same way here
um that you know they look a little
different
but overall it's pretty much the same
concept so
we made a couple matches you see nothing
moved through the trapdoors there
because we didn't open up any space
below them
um
the same thing here if we match over
here nothing will happen
we basically have to just set up a match
in the left hand side here so that we
can move some down all right so now we
can make
this one
and this is gonna this is gonna move
three peppers here
and then watch how these ones end up
after
see that they all moved
this pepper stayed behind so they all
moved basically two tiles down through
the door
now this is a four pepper match
so keep an eye on where these are at now
and um
this is going to clear out three so this
one is going to move down this direction
that one also created a shock wave so
you can see that it cleared out the
whole column
this is another one three three pepper
match move them down
and
that's pretty much all there is to it
on a level like this you can see that
we have statues
here so when we make a match on this
side you know we know we can get a hit
there
if we didn't want them to move around
like say we were trying to start a chain
reaction where this one's trapped
then we'd make them in the outside row
on this side or on this side
or in here as well
so you see we can
stack those up and then that'll still
that'll stay relatively in place i mean
it's going to move
whenever the other ones explode as well
but
that's the basic idea of it
on some levels it's a little bit more
complicated
um let's see
on this one
they're kind of blocked by the cages in
the beginning
but if we make a match you'll see the in
inboxes are here
and here
those end up down in the bottom these
are the exits and then you kind of have
to look around because these are entry
trap doors
but the exits are at the top when i
first played this i was like well where
they go when they come out of this they
come into this to this column
so that's that's pretty much all there
is to it i mean they're they're fairly
simple i'm sure in later levels they'll
get a little bit more complicated but
everything you need to know is in our
guide
so if you have any questions leave a
comment and we'll get back to you i hope
this helps understand how they work
thanks